Anna vanston here and a new sneak peek
of the Mario movie revealed Seth Rogen's
voices Donkey Kong and introduced Cat
Mario to the plot originally introduced
in Super Mario 3D World Mario transforms
into Cat Mario via the super Bell and
can swipe at his enemies and climb up
walls of that ability so maybe we'll get
some wall climbing action in his fight
with Donkey Kong another cool detail is
that it looks like the Huts in Donkey
Kong Country will be styled after the
Kong's Hut in Donkey Kong Country
Returns and I know I've said it before
but I am convinced that that's Diddy in
the background for all your Mario movie
coverage be sure to check out my
breakdowns on new rock stars